with only 24 hours to try and reel this
place in I need to find out what they
were doing wrong so my team told the
restaurant that they were trying out for
a traditional renovation show whilst
they were being interviewed we installed
hidden cameras throughout the restaurant
and I've been secretly recording
surveillance footage ever since we
left now as you know when people know
I'm coming to town they all turn on the
Southern Charm so I'm going
undercover Larry the luggage guy let's
go and eat some catfish gentlemen good
morning code name Larry so first is Ryan
Ryan Rob Rob JJ JJ good to see you ready
yes
okay let's go here we go Catfish Cabin
established in
1971 looks like it was closed in 1971
jet let's do
this hey how y'all doing how are you
doing 40 day okay
what does that
smell this used to be like one of my
favorite spots really you know what
happened go I seen three ants dragging a
hush puppy across the ground no hey
y'all how y'all doing today we're
ordering classic Memphis comfort food
the kind that made the cabin famous let
me do uh the hamburger steak french
fries as well fried shrimp and your deep
fried corn can catfish Shrimp Basket all
right I've got a hamburger steak cook
medium
yeah puppy huh how greasy are these look
at my fingers and more grease puppies
grease puppies that's
right it's going to be forever cooking
it is I want it flattened out some I
don't know he might mush it down or
something oh
I'm how can this food take so long we've
been sat here for half an hour right
I get them it don't matter hamburger
steak
medium uh fish and shrimp you had
macaroni oh boy the fish looks terrible
my catfish is all soy and Limp a t
slimy
oh oh my God is it even done no feel
like it's been dipped in Dish water what
is that hamburger
hamburger I mean seriously how
disgusting does yours look oh my God it
is
bad it's undercooked it's r in the
middle oh man enough don't eat anymore
chance I'm
done ladies and
gentlemen all of you stop eating Forks
down
Madam can you get me the kitchen out oh
boy y'all we need it on the floor he
told me to come get y'all and bring
y'all to the front you for real yeah
come
on come on let's go see what this is
It's a air huh
Charles Madam just come
through look
at
D is that shf
[Music]
oh oh my God first of all I've just sat
here for the last 60 minutes with my
guests and I've eaten some of the worst
Food I've ever tasted what an insult to
Memphis the Catfish Cabin is closed
immediately now as you know when people
know I'm coming they all tend to be on
their best behavior
[Music]
so I'm going undercover that's
massive grandma Jean ready for
lunch
hello hello happy Birthday gorgeous
thank you I love you you ready for lunch
ready for lunch my teeth are
in and we are ready to go go baby okay
you got your
license oh dear God God dear
[Music]
God I should have brought my handicap
sticker here we
go do you drive at home uh I
don't where's your
manners I don't have any she doesn't
have any hello welcome how are you good
thank you oh what smells in here you
smell it
yeah I know let's get
[Laughter]
out ladies do you smell that what is
that smell I have no idea smells like
something is off it's horrible hello
everybody how are you welcome to sow to
see if Peter can cook as well as he
claims we're ordering some classic fine
dining dishes I think I'm going to have
the orange I'm have the salmon and
he Jean would like
thein absolutely that's one of my
favorites thank you so much you're
welcome thank you you said
hey but Rock pan duck the range mushroom
salmon Sesame tuna
well we go die oh only if there's a
merciful
god look at that view I like it's one of
the most gorgeous settings I've ever
seen isn't that wonderful you look
inside the dining room how shabby it is
look how dingy that car is disgusting
the restaurant is drab everything here
is just beige beige beige beige beige
everywhere so dated if it wasn't for
that view outside there'd be nobody here
nobody here we are I have the
H the duck duck is me here you are thank
you it's burnt got dry your
salmon that's salmon
yeah oh my God it's
dry sorry sorry might taste a little bit
of duck as well
pleas oh my God it's terrible rubbery
and
dry oh my God hi everybody how's
everything everything
cooked it you like it
okay to eat the bread terrible yeah that
Lobster s don't eat any Lobster there's
a sour taste in that
Lobster could you cook better at home I
can could you cook better at home yes
could you cook better jeez listen I got
to get out of
there have I got a I got a
wedgie she is
hysterical the food is shocking the
smell is terrible those ladies all
agreed that they could cook better
food let's
go now as you know when people know I'm
coming they tend to sing a different
tune so I'm going
undercover look at that he's a
beauty softball Steve let's see if this
family can step up to the
plate Kansas City Slickers you ready for
some interesting food absolutely we
ready yes yeah I'll
drive so you guys drive on the opposite
side in UK okay we do oh is your
steering wheel over here it is oh cool
yeah so I get home [__] it I just sit in
the middle
let's do it
jents all the windows are tinted so you
got no idea what it is inside and that's
a good thing because no one would step
foot in here if they could see the
poorly imitated Mar gr
Decor how you fell doing did y want to
start with uh try our appetizers Cajun
Hush Puppies we're ordering some Creole
Staples red gumb which should be a
walk-off home run for any decent Cajun
restaurant black and catfish I'll do the
shrip Stu I'd like the Crawfish spirit
but after what we've already seen I'm
expecting this meal to be a swing and
Miss I think that'll do it thank you
Manan Hush Puppies gumbo and jumbalaya
and then the black and catfish sha who
this go to it's the last ticket that
came in I'm not sure y'all hopping
around on tickets I can't do
that service is terrible thought we'd
have an appetizer by now hush cfee where
you at is it a puppy up there I think it
is they probably cold at this point all
right got some hush puppies all
right so it smells like the oil in the
fryer hasn't been changed for weeks that
smell man that's not
good Miss Norma you know you got a
gumball and a jumbalaya no I do not it's
on the ticket with the black and catfish
yeah cuz y'all need to pay attention
more it's happens way too often okay
this probably needs to go
[Music]
out what's I do have the gumbo right
here yeah that was me jumbalaya cfish
bread and black and
C look at my catfish holy
Moses that's terrible my fish is
dry how this this come it looks more
like Sala there's something rubbery in
it it tastes like it's
turned oh my God Bo that crawfish GRE
you're not kidding me it looks like
vomit on a plate that's not how they do
crawfish toast in your Orleans trust me
get your ticket out first and then drop
chicken don't do that stop shut [__]
keep talking to me crazy for real I'm
not real can y'all
be Miss Norma sh Miss nor me and Miss
Norma know how to handle each other no
you don't we got orders we ain't got
time for that no ma'am won't you just
shut up ra talking to me who you talking
to because he's stepping up on me what
is going on in there don't step up on me
though your dad I'm about to stamp up on
you for real oh God she
just s question would you bring your
wives and girlfriends here after this
experience no no absolutely not no I
guess unless I wanted a
divorce now when people know I'm coming
trust me they do their best to stay in
line so I'm going undercover time to
race some
[Music]
H walking in broadwalk 11 feels like two
different restaurants the bar is state
of the the art while the restaurant is
in a state of despair and complete
neglect oh that's where the I guess the
karaoke happens I you guys know what you
want I think so yeah for the table we'll
take the sliders beef to go with that
geg in the corner we're ordering some
Gastropub
Staples uh can I do the meatballs all
right the Western best of burger all
right you
go the decco is tra right how about is
that something's in there
man tell whoever runs this place they
lost enthusiasm about the place a long
time ago it feels that way doesn't it we
still need meatballs got
it oh here we go oh there's there's the
ones got your beef sliders order
meatballs and Kei Western cool thanks
sweet the fact of how fast this food's
coming out is just processed yeah yeah
defrosted and Frozen
smells like dog food the meat and these
slies smell like they've gone
bad it's sour it's it's turned are you
serious the meatballs smell just like
the burger is that what that smell is my
God it smells like the carpet W it is
disgusting I'm going to take your word
for that
one oh boy right going to cut into that
burger is that lettuce God knows what it
is the bu is soaking wet yeah and the
meat is
gray oh my God BL Dead on Arrival we
called the bastard Burger yeah he is the
biggest bastard in La preparing a burger
like that my God
terrible um ladies and
Gentlemen please can I ask you to put
your knife and forks
down
first of
all that was one of the worst meals I've
ever had I'm in
shock honestly you guys should be
ashamed
[Music]
Gord cuz that was
embarrassing dirty menus thrown down
then the food
arrived I've never seen food hit the
table so quick in all my [__] life
I sense it's being microwav and then
literally just thrown down cat you're
the head chef right sure just out of
Interest how long AG go those meatballs
cooked like 4 days
ago what is this just a dive bar we
thought we had pretty decent food we
were trying our best I'm lost for words
and you're saying the food is good
saying the food is good it's not great
but it's the best that we can do that
was a [__] embarrassment everybody
else stop eating broadwalk 11
is close meet me
outside can't even stand up
straight right hit me so I'm going
undercover Grandpa Jim ready for
lunch
Anette how are you gorgeous I'm fine
nice to see you Brian and Walter best
behavior please yes papa belts on no how
does this thing start oh oh jeez [__]
that's a long time since the pass the
driving test okay let's
go thank God there's no dress
code
hey unfortunately there doesn't appear
to be a dress code for the restaurant's
interior either the assortment of colors
in here on the chairs is ridiculous it's
like a rainbow of
mess and how in the [__] do you get
through these menus on one side of the
menu you've got potential dishes on the
other side you've got ads I mean how
tacky is that upholstery oh my God we
got tile here the menu is 22 pages long
I may die before I get to the end of it
that's before [__]
[Music]
eating you guys ready to order or you
want to wait a few minutes maybe some
beef tamales beef tames we're ordering
some classic Mexican dishes I'm going to
get the chicken mle the shrimp uh goes
that a place like Los Tauros should have
mastered can I get
a
CH thank you guys all right thank
you hey Dad yeah
huh at least that's what we're
thinking 95% where
15 I think they fast sponsor it is me
yeah Chef Ramsey it's going to be him I
know it's going to be him I got it Tamal
first so one for each
okay let me get more napins okay it does
not scream fresh T
huh you want to served in a nice corn
husk yeah exactly kind of make it
somewhat look homemade honey will you
stop eating that [__] thing
I need you
tonight it's my birthday you promise me
see this one right
here goes out with the I'm going to go
look for myself right now what up guys
two orders of shrim tacos and the car
Sal chicken Mo you guys that's
me9 the beef tastes tough almost like
it's turned cuz it smells oh yeah you
can tell it's old yeah fcking
out
how's that chicken W it's really bad the
aftertaste is like
poing ladi's watching us now so have to
be
careful yeah they keep on staring
over I'm going out to the car to change
my colos bag because it's coming through
quicker than I
expected
[Music]
MERS is holding on for dear life so my
team told the restaurant that they were
trying out for a traditional renovation
show whilst they were been interviewed
we installed hidden cameras throughout
the restaurant and I've been secretly
recording sellan footage ever since we
left even with the best disguise in this
tiny little restaurant I'll stick out
like a sore thumb do you have any idea
how long it take me to grow this so I've
decided to go un under cover to hide in
plain sides cameraman buddy ready for
[Music]
action hiding behind this camera I feel
invisible so the decor is Dreadful this
place is run down it clearly hasn't seen
love in years who wants to sit down on
that thing D through a hot sauce
do you know if we're going to have
oxtails at all today no 86
oxtails there's no more grits all we
have is country potatoes more how you be
a black restaurant well I don't know we
ran out [__] I'm just a
w 86 lot of items clearly no love loss
on the food either why are you guys
holding on to the dishes so much that's
why they're always calling back for
[__]
you all doing okay you were supposed to
bring me a you forgot all about me I'm
waiting on the dish man uhuh you forgot
about me don't trip I'm going to forget
about your ass right now I don't even
want that I said smother bro man you
didn't say no smother it don't say that
on your
receipt time eat some lunch sitting down
in the restaurant would blow my cover so
Ernie and I taken up food to
go um visually it looks as bad in here
as it does on the plates I mean it's
just slopped yeah again so that's a
fried chicken with uh greens I mean it
just looks old there's not a lot of
flavor there's no flavor there
whatsoever and the suddenly not seasoned
on the
breading well how are those greens um
they need a lot more seasoning yeah do
you notice that every customer throwing
salt yeah pepper pepper everywhere I
peppered it twice mhm
Ah that's Bland so the fried chicken in
the greens a big no no right fried
catfish sandwich that tart sauce that
stinks do smell
that oh meatloaf W that's meat looks
like something that's sort of slipped
out my granddad's underpants look at
that that gravy there whatever that is
on there that's just
Grim don't do it oh oh my God that is
terrible get back in there yeah yeah
right let's
[Music]
go um ladies and gentlemen can I just
ask you to stop eating KN Forks down
turn off the stove oh that's Gordon
Ramsey oh wait that's a fake
beard oh you the me
Che can I just have silence for 30
seconds please stop eating Madam Carrie
I've been here for the last 90 minutes I
understand while the resturant is
struggling MERS is officially closed can
you all follow me please I ain't going
to do too well with him as you know when
people know I'm coming they all tend to
be on their best BL Behavior so I'm
going
[Music]
undercover Deputy Connor reporting for
Duty morning good morning how are we
good Jerry right yes good to see you
osar good to see you still still nice to
see you thank you so much so i' pass as
an officer yes do you want me to drive
no I'll drive oh
[__] let's go
[Music]
so this restaurant had a great
reputation oh yeah M definitely is it on
your list now or have you crossed that
off crossed it off crossed it
off let's hope it looks better on the
inside of the
outside at The Trolley Stop Cafe
sheriff's deputies eat at a discount but
as I look around at the mismatch tables
and filthy Decor I would hope that
discount means free can tell that
there's no manager present how you guys
doing hi my name isita I do server y
ready to order yeah I'm ready to order
we're ordering Classic Diner dishes I'm
going to get a seafood omelet that any
New Orleans restaurant should consider a
big easy and can I add a um peacon
waffle to it too yeah going get the
fried chicken sandwich the natural
cheese let say Co booy what you want uh
[Music]
FR thank you
you got a waffle
[Music]
down so we've been here 20 minutes now
okay the owner is nowhere to be
seen J will you do me a favor will you
uh jump on the vehicle and go get in for
me okay do you mind yeah know yeah I'll
keep the food warm all right thank yeah
and don't get for
speeding SE homet cheese bre white toast
yep ARA po boy thank you your
naos man smell can you smell that smells
hard that has a
smell
that cheese is
sour oh boy look at my oysters that's
the oyster
[Music]
there so [__] that's not
good
well guys this is some of the most
disgusting food I've ever seen uh please
don't eat anything else okay yes sir I
got to set this out I'll be back in a
minute thank
you at cheese on the nachos Jesus
[Music]
Christ let's get the [__] out of here my
new friends and I are posing as fans of
the local hockey team the Lehigh Valley
Phantoms it's a great area around here
isn't it this is yeah this is a nice
area right here it's been redone
vitalized
yeah oh there it is okay guys let's go
let's break it hungry
hungry you got a black and scallop app
Tommy
all oh Bo g hi guys welcome to chant how
are you thank you four four of us when
you walk into theant it pays homage to
its name a crude rundown Shack did you
guys want to hi up yes perfect thank you
the decor is lacking any sort of
identity and it feels more like a sports
bar than an upscale beastro that would
serve the local theater crowd and man
you look at the size of this [__]
huge are you guys ready to order do you
need a few minutes I think we're good
you guys ready with a menu that lacks
any clear Direction you know what I
think I'm just going to have the shrimp
Florentine please we're ordering a hot
bot of menu items I have the black and
filet medium rare please hopefully this
meal doesn't land Us in The Penalty Box
black and skelets I have to go for the
Goon Burger o yep never sold that before
thank you very much than you you they've
never sold a goomber before yeah I found
that interesting kind of compliments
that give you as a customer for [__]
sake come on Kennedy tast I need that
Mojo St it's coming Joe it's [__]
coming all the rest of the food went out
5 minutes you want me to [__] do I
[__] onions I don't have [__]
onions I'm one [__] person don't tell
me to a [__]
shush the [__] dude she's in an open
kitchen and she is absolutely swearing a
head off I can hear from here get off my
[__]
ass very sorry about that um just under
a lot of pressure customers don't want
to hear that no I got another black and
scallop on the
board black and scallops
so black and scars is this a joke they
look
burn oh my God mine doesn't even taste
fresh they taste Frozen how long that
black and F Tommy 2 minutes at least her
minutes we've been sat here for 45
minutes guys still no on track
[Music]
all right shrimp florentin that's me
goon
Burger
wow my burger is St cold I just try that
shrimp one help
yourself don't eat too much of those
shrimp please they taste sour blood to
Hell there's nothing fresh here 9% of
what we're eating is Frozen I'll be back
in a minute all right please don't eat
too much yep
[Music]
okay wow that was
bad the scallops w't blackened the
scolars were
[Music]
cremated when people know I'm coming
they all tend to be on their best Bloody
Behavior so I'll be blending in to the
crowd office manager Bob time for
lunch how are we great Daniel right yeah
Grant welcome Rocco Rocco good to see
you meet you we got the same uh yeah
same going on are we ready for some
lunch yeah jump in I'm going to drive
right oh my Lord here we go what side of
the road you drive on here left or
right
wow that sign looks terrible this place
looks like an abandoned strip club honey
thank
you what's that
smell my name is Jen and I'm going to be
taking care of you you thank
you the decor is terrible it's dull
dingy it looks like a a funeral home oh
my God french onion soup in an Italian
restaurant oh my God we're ordering
classic dishes you guys want colar
stuffed shrimp that any self-respecting
Italian restaurant should have perfected
chicken parmesan I can't stand chicken
parmesan out of a million beautiful food
items in the world why would you order
chicken parmesan love the pistachio
scrub lingu all right your calamari
should be right up so thank
you let we have onion soup and a
calamari the calamari is all different
sizes because they cut it frozen and it
sucks right here we go the calamari
there go sorry about the thank you
you're
welome calari is terrible rubber hard
it's old damn please don't eat too much
guys please 25 minutes in still no ENT
TR I mean 10 minutes time we need to go
back to work chick par is laging I got
to get one
[Music]
breaded there's no energy there's no
passion and that starts from the
top all right here we go pistachio scrad
there you go you're welcome chicken
parmesan thanks so much and there you go
dear Lord above please may we don't have
the [__] for 4 days amen good luck
everybody how much breading's on there
shrimp a lot why is there so much
breading on there hi of shrimp they're
old shrimps are old too oh my God they
stinking Nows FS please don't eat too
much of that stuffing please please
please how CLS I think they've
turned yeah my God they're
gone dead never ever cook dead shellfish
my go guys I've seen enough Give Me 2
minutes thank you excuse
me oh my
God okay terrible food terrible service
drab deor and this owner he's given up
it's clearly
evidence